Xbox one owners will finally be able to
directly upload gameplay clips to
YouTube putting an end to the convoluted
process of old I'm mark Walton and this
is a gamespot news update in a blog post
on the xbox wire microsoft said once the
new YouTube update rolls out tomorrow it
will be easier than ever to capture and
share game clips with people around the
world when the update is released you'll
be able to click a button inside the
YouTube app to share your clips directly
to your YouTube channel by comparison
Sony's PlayStation 4 does not offer any
YouTube app whatsoever though owners of
that system can share clips to their
profiles or to Facebook using the system
share functionality the PlayStation 3
and PlayStation Vita currently have
dedicated YouTube apps the updated
YouTube app for xbox one will also let
you watch videos and snap mode have new
videos to your pins and media
achievements and add your favorite
YouTube channels to the one guide but
are you excited by the prospect of
YouTube being flooded with thousands
upon thousands of hours of gameplay
videos let us know in the comments below
and for more on the latest gaming news
keep it gamespot
you